[Musique]
pas plus d'un euro 99 le litre de
carburant dans les stations Total
énergie en 2023 le PDG du groupe
petrolier s'est engagé sur un
plafonnement des prix il est déjà en
vigueur sur les autoroutes et le sera
dans le reste du pays à partir du 1er
mars le dieselium et le sans-plomb 98
sont exclus de la mesure ce plafonnement
va concerner près d'une quarantaine de
stations de la marque dans les Yvelines
Navigo abonnement suspendu vous avez
peut-être reçu récemment ce mail avec en
objet cette mention attention
Île-de-France mobilité alerte sur ses
courriers électroniques frauduleux qui
circulent auprès des abonnés du Pass
Navigo ils contiennent un lien qui
renvoie vers une plateforme de
renseignements des coordonnées bancaires
c'est une arnaque en quête d'un pays
c'est un SMS qui vous est envoyé pour
inviter à contacter le service client
une notification vous est faite
également sur votre espace personnel le
syndicat des transports franciliens a
porté plainte
les vacances d'hiver vont se poursuivre
pour une deuxième semaine et forcément
ce week-end cela risque de générer
quelques bouchons Bison Futé voie orange
dans le sens des départs vendredi il est
conseillé de quitter ou de traverser
l'Île-de-France avant 14h c'est Orange
également samedi mais dans le sens des
retours pour éviter les perturbations il
vaut mieux rejoindre la région avant 14h
éviter également l'autoroute A43 entre
Chambéry et Lyon dimanche tous les
voyants sont au vert soyez prudents sur
les routes et pensez à faire des pauses
régulièrement les premières images du
futur complexe du Val Fourré ont été
révélés il devrait sortir de terre en
2025 à Mantes-la-Jolie en lieu et place
de l’ancien collège Chénier ce site de
plus de 5000 m² se composera de deux
bâtiments dont un gymnase principal de
350 places budget pour la première phase
des travaux plus de 10 millions d'euros
enfin il devrait y avoir du beau monde
sur les routes du Paris-Nice le Slovène
tadaï pogacchar double vainqueur du Tour
de France vient de confirmer sa
participation il fera face notamment au
néerlandais Ionas vinghorn victorieux
sur la Grande Boucle l'an passé et gagne
Bernal qui s'est imposé lors de la
course le soleil en 2019 pour également
faire son retour de blessure sur le
Paris-Nice d'après une information de la
Gazzetta dello Sport elle a 81e édition
de la course cycliste s’élancera le 5
mars de la verrière pour une boucle dans
les Yvelines le départ de la deuxième
étape se fera de base en ville le
lendemain direction Fontainebleau
[Musique]